no matter this is many the middle aspect
all is so much harder than when you're
swimming six to ten hours by yourself I
started running out of things
think about your mind starts getting
exhausted my name is Chris rain and I
swim the entire length of the
Mississippi River
it took me 181 days the Mississippi
River is two thousand three hundred and
twenty miles long
beginning in Minnesota it empties into
the Gulf of Mexico
and in 2015 Chris rang took it on to
raise awareness and honor gold star
families both star families a family
that's lost a loved one in service to
our country
it's truly inspiring so I want you
something so he took on the mighty
Mississippi it's an amazing powerful
river you don't really know what to
expect we did as much research as
possible and what you'll face in the
Mississippi you see a little wildlife
out there you'll see all the Eagles
flying around a lot of alligators stuff
like that one thing that I was really
kind of surprised about was how biggest
swells get in the river you know I
didn't expect 10 plus foot swells the
only time that I would not swim was when
there was a fog so if they're storms
still swimming through the storms you
know we did hit some pretty big storms
going down the river one storm he
remembers in particular making good time
and before you know it this guy just
pitch black it's just sideways rain
winds changing constant direction
lightnings flashing around and you can
feel it isn't so close to you you can
feel it in the water and there's nothing
really can do at that point you know
it's your wedding out well I've always
had a high respect and appreciation for
nature there's data it took me an hour
just to go half a mile just seeing how
quickly that river to change not only
from weather but you know the currents
so new appreciation for what that river
itself for what
what you'll face in the Mississippi